are you ready to code a mostly fluid
layout you've already seen this layout
before but you haven't had a chance to
modify its CSS yet for this quiz you'll
be adding some CSS breakpoints to some
HTML so that the page layouts match what
you see here here let me show you what
you'll be doing in the head of the
document you'll find two style tags the
first style tag just has default styles
and you don't need to change these here
let me close them the second style tag
includes the responsive styles and this
is where you're going to put your
breakpoints my advice is to write the
initial breakpoints in the source file
with classes that you might want to
modify at that breakpoint then open the
page in the browser and toy with the
styles using dev tools if you've got the
style set that you think look right go
ahead and change the source files also
try playing around with the order while
you're messing around with breakpoints
it's actually pretty fun check this box
once your layout matches the sites that
you see here good luck